welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
invincible season 2 episode 4 titled
it's been a while which is what Nolan
said to Mark at the end of last episode
and also what we will be saying when
they air the rest of season 2 which
isn't set to be released until early
2024 at that point I'm going to have a
kid and yeah this episode made me
terrified of all father's child
relationships Happy Thanksgiving let's
break down for all the Easter eggs
animation details and deeper layers of
meaning that you might have missed we
open on the events of the season 1
finale where Nolan is looking at his
bloody hands after beating Mark almost
to death the scene is replayed exactly
except now notice the sound mix on
certain things is cranked up marks
shuddering gasps for breath the sound of
the blood dripping on the Rocks Nolan's
Cape flapping in the wind and Mark's
child like Dad they are all louder than
they were when we first saw this
scene dad that is because we are hearing
it from Nolan's perspective not only
does as a Vite he have heightened
hearing In This Moment everything is
standing out to him as he reckons with
what he has done he has been stung with
something he's never felt before that
thing is love as Nolan flies out of the
atmosphere Mark's blood Burns off of his
suit and from his face like he is
desperate to cleanse himself of this
love thing and included in that cleanse
leaving behind an Earth's orbit a couple
teardrops floating in space that
teardrop fills the frame cleansing us as
we stay on Nolan and we see the events
of the aformentioned while of the past
Fe the song playing is Avalanche which
was originally by Leonard Cohen but it's
sung here by Nick Cave cave had actually
recorded a version of this in 1984 with
his band Nick Cave in the bad seeds and
in that version he was much more defiant
his voice had a hard mocking quality but
he re-recorded it solo 31 years later in
2015 and the result was this more lonely
and more reflective version that we hear
there have been many interpretations of
the meaning behind Avalanche over the
years that it's a song about a spiritual
struggle and redemption or that it's a
metaphor for the end of a relationship
but I think that what it represents here
is a god-like figure Nolan who thinks
that he has no real need for the love
and worship bestowed upon him in fact
there's almost a resentment or disdain
in the lyrics he does not ask for your
company not at the center of the World
by the end of the song that figure
discovers that not only did he need it
but that now that it's gone he misses it
I have begun to long for you I who have
no greed I have begun to ask for you I
who have no need Nolan thought for all
these years that he knew his mission he
was in control and that his family was
mainly for show pets he was a strong one
and they needed him more than he needed
them but having them taken away now he
feels purposeless and he doesn't know
who he is without their love and he
feels the very human emotion of longing
we see Nolan flying away from Earth and
through the vastness of space he goes
from this ramrod straight posture and
straight flight path to a more hunched
or hunched backed bedraggled path you
can tell he's no longer flying as fast
as he can because of how his cape just
sort of lazily Billows instead of
sticking straight out behind him even
though you know there is no wind in
space and his cape is like part of his
suit but I guess the cape would be like
tugged behind him and don't ask me how
forces work in space but yeah our man's
got a decent amount of facial hair now
we see him sitting on a cliff of some
unknown and seemingly uninhabited planet
with two sons one big son one small son
reminding him of course of himself and
Mark and you can see one set of
footprints behind him meaning he has set
down on this planet and has been walking
its lonely surface then he flies by this
destroyed planet or Moon that's emitting
blue light from the center of it then by
what looks like a star in the midst of
going Supernova then by this beautiful
space Aurora balis looking thing a kind
of nebula sometime later he looks at the
Event Horizon of a black hole and it has
the same design as the black hole that
they created for the movie Interstellar
as Nolan lets the gravitational pole
start to suck him in the only thing that
stops him from killing himself is a
crashing traxen ship appearing at first
like a star from the heavens Nolan
intervenes before it starts to hit the
black hole and saves its occupants four
of them which at first kind of seemed
like a kind of draxen fantastic po but
notice how this youngest is a girl and
since the average THX and lifespan is a
year and they age super fast this is
Andressa the thraen that Nolan Mar's
which is kind of gross her adult form
even wears the same outfit that she
wears as a girl and I just realized that
this is Nolan staring at a black hole
borrowing the same designs from
Christopher Nolan's black hole so Nolan
wants to leave thraxa but they convince
him to stay and we transition back to
the present with his hand still
outstretched to Mark yes this whole
opening sequence is very similar to one
from another Robert Kirkman property The
Walking Dead season 4 episode 6 live Bae
which follows the governor's loss of
Hope in his Redemption Montage that
showed us what happened to him after he
massacred most of his followers and was
abandoned by the rest at the end of the
that sequence the governor found new
purpose when he rescued a woman and her
daughter from some Walkers to examine
whether people can come back from the
worst things that they've done and given
how that all ended for the governor I
don't have a ton of Hope for Nolan's
future mark clenches his fist Nolan does
the same now look Mark is dressed in his
Invincible suit and Nolan is wearing a
variation of zombie Man suit with
trappings of the fracks and monarchs so
they aren't reuniting as themselves as
Father and Son but really as their
superhero alter egos who have different
obligations than just family Mark takes
off his mask and he tries to make his
dead Flinch causing a puff of wind to
push Nolan's Cate but then he cannot
help it he launches himself at his dad
to give him a hug and while it seems
like a loving gesture remember this love
is a poisoned Stinger for Nolan he
doesn't know what to do with this kind
of thing but then Mark takes a moment to
process and he realizes that his dad
totally lied to him to get him here and
of course remembers when he called his
mom a pet and killed thousands of people
and yeah he's pissed he only agrees to
stay and hear his dad out when Nolan
insists that the thrin do need his help
Nolan is playing on his empathy and can
I just take a moment to say how great it
is to hear a character say you so many
times repeatedly in a superhero genre
like I wanted to hear characters in the
MCU say this to each other and I just
love and it's very R-rated show we get
to just hear character speak honestly to
each other as they would now Mark has to
watch his dad tongue kiss and dress up
which is straight out of the comics and
then we get this reveal Mark Welcome to
our home my husband's told me so much
about you and dress up and he doesn't
even have time to wrap his mind around
it because the hits just keep on coming
this is your little
brother you got to be yeah we get the
Invincible title cutting off the curse
word for the first time but it actually
Cuts back and Mark continues what he was
saying kidding me okay now we see
Debbie who is still walking alone after
Theo told her not to come back to the
spouse of a superhero support group last
episode she gets her own wandering
Montage with the exact same kind of
storyboarding that we saw with Nolan
Debbie's background is changing as she
moves from the left to the right now she
was walking all night at some point she
discarded her shoes she is looking rough
the music we hear is Olympus by blond
shell it's a song that examines an
unhealthy relationship ship comparing it
to an addiction Debbie walks down an
empty Street by some empty swings
through an empty unhoused encampment
before the city starts to wake up her
version of considering throwing herself
into a black hole happens when she is
standing on an overpass watching the
traffic below her we really do think for
a second that she might jump but unlike
her husband there isn't a crashing ship
to distract her instead she moves on and
goes to Nolan's grave which obviously
has no body in it so even in this she's
alone wondering why did he even take the
time to bring her on as a pet why not
just take the planet so we cut briefly
to the MERS the scarred one having
created a new clone and this time it's
clear who the Clone is and who the
original is but remember back in season
one they said that it never ends well
when they have that knowledge we had to
make it seamless otherwise one of us
knows he's the Clone and that never ends
well actually later the mid-credit scene
shows a new mer clone poisoning the
scarred mer with a microt toxin
returning things to the status quo
Donald comes looking for answers about
what happened to him at the end of
season 1 and he finds his old glasses in
the rubble of the house across the
street back on THX on Nolan tries to
convince Mark that he didn't replace him
or his mom it's kind of hard to tell how
much of this is Nolan being genuine how
much is just more manipulation like when
he tells Mark that the vilter might
rules of vure breeding are very specific
and that they'll come to kill this baby
that's obviously true still this is
something that he knew before he had a
kid with a thren and he's once again
relying on Mark's empathy to help him
clean up a mess that he created three
vites show up these are the same three
that beat Allan almost to death last
episode and they don't even check to see
if Nolan is there they just start
crashing into buildings and yeah they're
rayon's everyday ear earbuds
have been a staple of my leaving the
house kit for years the sound quality
and the noise isolating are just such a
step up from the other earbuds I've
tried that I keep coming back to them
every time I need to run to the coffee
shop or the grocery store anywhere
really you really should pick up a pair
either for yourself or as a gift for the
audio lover in your life and right now
is a perfect time to do so because
raycon has Black Friday and Cyber Monday
promotions across their entire site with
select products up to 50% off raycon is
also offering limited time bundles the
fitness audio kit includes Fitness
earbuds and headphones and the everyday
audio kit includes the everyday earbuds
and headphones or you can mix and match
any three raycon products and colors to
build your own bundle these specials are
only available for one week so make sure
to shop by November 27th if you've
already got a pair of earbuds check out
rayon's new home and Powertech like
their faucet filter and Magic 180 cable
shop raycon Black Friday and Cyber
Monday sales for their biggest holiday
discounts yet go to buy ron.com neww
rockstars to get up to 50% off sitewide
meanwhile kill cannon that's the villain
we saw in season 1 who has a laser
cannon for an arm he tries to rob the
robot's energy sphere from the Guardians
of the globe headquarters Eve stops him
she kicks his ass on this bridge even
though she's Tred not to let innocent
people get caught in the crossfire this
older couple's car Falls over the bridge
into the water Eve manages to take out
kill Canon and bring the couple up from
the surface as the ambulances arrive but
it's not clear if they are alive as Eve
just asks are they okay please just help
them she's thinking about the last time
she tried to help people that city park
that she built had collapsed and injured
those people Mark brings and dressa and
his half brother to a cave hidden in the
Mountainside and gets to know the dad's
new wife a bit he learns that the THX
and lifespan is only one year and
Nolan's jeans slowed his half Brothers
aging but they're still way ahead of
where a human baby would be Now spoiler
warning about the future of this
character in the comics in the comics
this baby later picks the name of Oliver
and he goes on to become the superhero
kid omn man now despite the fact that
Nolan was hurt and Clos up when an
addessa met him she fell in love with
him anyway before she knew about Mark or
his mom and again just reminding she was
a little girl when she met him Nolan
Nolan right as she's about to finish
telling Mark how much his dad loves him
they are found by the vmite Lucan who
also rocks a mustache what is it about
these guys in their stashes lukan finds
andessa and the kid under a rock and
considers him bugs Mark fights him and
lukan just uses a single finger to shove
Mark into the ground Nolan slices Lucan
in the gut with his hand move that we
saw him do before when he chopped off
the Immortals head in season 1 and yeah
most of the Guardians of the globe in
the very first episode of the series and
remember Nolan from a different
dimension used the same chop to take off
the immortal's arm and his head in the
first episode of this season then Nolan
impales Lucan with a stalactite and
given that we find out later that he
survived this it shows us how insanely
resilient the vites are Debbie turns one
of her Korean wedding Ducks away from
the other Korean wedding Ducks represent
family peace and Fidelity and when
facing one another happiness is in the
home so it makes sense why she would
want them facing apart she flips through
her family photo album but luckily art
drops by and she finally has someone to
talk to he says that he always thought
she was a strong one you you've got
strength living with Nolan standing up
to him raising Mark the way you did hell
you're the real reason we're all still
alive and not slaves or worse he credits
Debbie not Nolan with Mark's good
qualities and he adds that she made
things work without him and says you
don't need the bum you never did
remember earlier during their respective
montages Nolan had given up and was
ready to throw himself into that black
hole the only thing that stopped him was
this hero complex but when Debbie looks
out over the traffic nothing was there
to stop her she had to decide just for
herself not to jump despite everything
she didn't need to kind of outside
influence or hero complex or some kind
of like distraction coming into her
periphery she is stronger than he is so
in a way the fact that she has empathy
the fact that she feels guilt for
everything her husband did and has to
live with that guilt without having the
luxury of being a psychopath makes her
far stronger than he is meanwhile Donald
logs onto the servers using Cecil's
login and password no idea how he has
that information and he finds footage of
his own death later when he tries to cut
himself the knife bends there's a lot
going on with Donald and it seemed a bit
easy easy that he made this discovery
I'm just wondering if it's possible that
someone wanted Donald to figure things
out or maybe this is just a cycle that
has happened to him before Mark and
Nolan see scores of dead thin and Nolan
reacts why do I care about them I'm not
supposed to feel this way how is this
better it's just great voice acting from
JK Simmons Mark tells him that this is
how he should have felt on Earth and
that really hits home for Nolan he
chokes Mark throughout this rant which
is just you know horribly violent but
interesting that he blames Mark for
imbuing him with this empathy it's
something that hurts him and he has no
other defense to it the other two Ultram
mites arrive and Mark tries to talk to
the female who has this long braid with
a knife attached to the end of it pretty
sure this is Thula from the comics she
tells him that she will make it quick
since he's Nolan's son and at first Mark
is absolutely outmatched Nolan tells him
to stop holding back but Mark doesn't
want to kill people but upon seeing the
dead thrx and being reminded of all the
people whose blood is still on his hands
he begins to bring it so here we
intercut Mark versus Thula Nolan versus
the other and these fights are bloody
actually one insert shows Mark jabbing
his fingers into thul's throat like the
Neo versus the agent fight in the Matrix
Nolan cracks the male's skull it
smooshes it so that the eyes are
misaligned yet still this guy is briefly
alive trying to smush it back together
vit's made a tough stuff how how Mark
hesitates and Thula takes this
opportunity to stab him with her hair
knife and Mark in a moment of childlike
vulnerability calls for his dad who
intervenes and punches thul's jaw off
and it's one of the most gruesome deaths
we've seen on the show which is seing a
lot but it might just be her trembling
hands or her twitching eye or the
coughing sounds that she makes Lucan
returns literally holding his intestines
with his hands by bunching up and
swalling up his clothes he breaks
Nolan's back with a flying kick we hear
all the bones cracking and then says
it's done into a communication device
and this time both Mark and Nolan are
left bleeding on the Rocks other vites
arrive and take Lucan and Nolan away and
Nolan tells Mark not to forget the good
he did and the book said he wrote and we
meet General C who's a huge character in
the comics here he's voiced by Clancy
Brown telling Mark that his fighting
performance has proven him worthy of his
vmite Heritage Nolan will be executed he
says but Mark has to return to Earth to
take up Nolan's mission to repair earth
and its people for a Vite takeover if he
doesn't succeed the vites will kill
Millions Debbie tells Cecil that she
doesn't want the money from Nolan's
books anymore and to give that money to
the survivors in Chicago they need it
more now these books include Savage
Planet Savage beasts and the man with
the Invincible gun on the covers we see
a younger Nolan with that female
viltrumite that accompanied him in the
flashbacks with Allen the aliens home
planet with the UN opens and vums
Massacre of them now Nolan's books are
from Invincible number 35 from 2006 and
they're probably going to play a big
role in the second half of the season so
if you haven't read the comics and you
don't want to be spoiled feel free to
stop watching now and I'll see you in
2024 the man with the Invincible gun
tells the story of a legendary Alien
named space Rider AKA Space Racer who
carries a gun called The Infinity Ray
that was Unstoppable and goes through
anything planets stars and even bu
trites Nolan had fought this guy and he
caused him to drop this gun on an
asteroid belt and there that gun had
stayed I wonder actually if this Ray is
what angstrom Levy was trying to build
in that alternate reality in the season
premiere meanwhile Savage Planet Savage
beasts is about the Ragnar and how their
planet's gravity made them super strong
and capable of injuring Nolan with ease
causing him tremendous pain despite
their small size while omn man sold
these stories as if they were fictional
Tales they are actually true accounts
and noan leaves in these books a message
for Mark about biltrite weaknesses it's
a pretty great turn in the comics and I
just love to see it here as a message to
Consumers of comic based media like this
that the greatest truths are in the
pages of the source material so read
children read and that is it for part
one of season 2 of invincible I can't
wait for the show to come back next year
in the meantime please support us by
grabbing a shirt from nerd ride. shop
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network follow me on all
socials at eaos Big thanks to Gina AO
for writing this breakdown thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
la